para seguir aprendiendo acerca de la
elasticidad de la demanda vamos a ver
algunos ejemplos extremos de este lado
tenemos un frasco de insulina frasco de
insulina la insulina la utilizan los
diabéticos bueno no todos pero muchos
diabéticos para regular los niveles de
azúcar en la sangre y si no la utilizan
les pueden empezar a pasar cosas malas
si su organismo puede empezar a tener
reacciones muy extrañas y pueden morir
más pronto lo cual no está padre
entonces pues es una prioridad consumir
estos frascos de insulina vamos a pensar
qué le sucede a la curva de demanda de
un bien de este estilo aquí voy a poner
el precio de cada frasco de insulina
voy a poner pesos por frasco pesos por
frasco y de este lado le voy a poner la
cantidad demandada digamos que está en
frascos por semana sí entonces imagínate
que tenemos un cierto grupo de personas
es que era un poco charco tenemos un
cierto grupo de personas que necesita
consumir 100 frascos de insulina
y ahorita la insulina está en 50 pesos
del frasco por decir algo entonces bueno
qué sucedería si cambia el precio de la
insulina si de 50 pesos baja a 5 pesos
cuál cantidad ahora necesitan los
diabéticos pues bueno necesitan todavía
100 frascos insulina a la semana es en
la dosis que necesitan recuerda la
cantidad demandada va a ser 100 porque
todo lo demás lo estamos dejando igual
no estamos pensando en las expectativas
de cambio de precio de la gente ni cosas
por el estilo
únicamente cambiando el precio pues la
cantidad demandada no se va a modificar
porque se necesita una dosis fija y más
de esa dosis no sirve de nada
de manera similar qué sucedería si el
precio cambia a 500 bueno si el precio
cambia 500 de las personas todavía
necesitan pues 100 frascos a la semana
este grupo necesita siempre ascos a la
semana y por tanto de todas formas van a
tener que comprar 100 a lo mejor van a
tener que hacer algunos sacrificios como
ir menos al cine o trabajar horas extra
pero la cosa es que necesitan esos 100
frascos a la semana estos se van a
seguir demandando claro ahora si
aumentamos esto muchísimo si el precio
aumenta a 500.000 pues a lo mejor pues
no no ya no lo van a poder pagar pero
dentro de la medida así de lo de lo
posible o digamos dentro de una cantidad
razonable si movemos esto de acá un
poquito o si lo movemos dentro de un
rango aceptable entonces la cantidad no
varía a este tipo de bienes se les
conoce como bienes perfectamente
inelásticos
perfectamente rectamente inelásticos y
elásticos sale entonces los cambios de
presión no afectan la cantidad la
analogía física sería pues como un
ladrillo no un ladrillo si le aplicas
una fuerza dentro de un intervalo
razonable pues no se va a estirar vale
muy bien entonces como se vería la
gráfica de algo de este estilo pues ve
la gráfica vamos a pintarla o sea la
gráfica desde la curva de demanda
la curva de demanda se vería más o menos
así de este lado tenemos precios de este
lado tenemos cantidad digamos que por
acá están 50 pesos para que están 50 por
acá están 5 entonces y aquí están 100
100 cantidades
100 100 frascos a la semana entonces si
el precio es de 5 se van a demandar 100
frascos cada semana si el precio es de
50 también si el precio es de 100
también y gps es de 500 también es decir
en todos estos valores se demandan si es
100 frascos de este modo tendríamos así
verticalmente
verticalmente la curva de demanda
entonces la curva de demanda es una
línea vertical vertical va entonces
tenemos una línea vertical cuál sería la
elasticidad de la demanda y eso también
es interesante verlo entonces si
queremos hacer el cálculo de la
elasticidad de la demanda cuánto nos
quedaría pues tenemos que ver el cambio
porcentual de la cantidad dividido entre
el cambio porcentual del precio verdad y
eso cuánto sería pues el cambio de la
cantidad sería ir de 100 a 100 por
ejemplo el cambio de acá para acá aquí
disminuye en 45 y aquí se mueve en 0
entonces el cambio porcentual de la
cantidad pues sería 0 dividido entre 100
que arriba nos queda 0 dividido entre y
bueno hay que utilizar este método del
promedio verdad dividido entre menos 45
entre el promedio de 5 y 50 o sea 55
entre 5 27.5 pero bueno la cosa es que
nos queda 0 dividido en alguien entre
algo
y 0 dividido entre cualquier cosa es
igual a 0 entonces en este caso de acá
lo que sucede es que la elasticidad de
la demanda en valor absoluto da 0 bueno
también sin valor absoluto de acero y la
gráfica queda de esta forma va entonces
en un bien perfectamente en elástico la
curva de demanda es vertical y la
elasticidad de la demanda es igual a
cero bueno qué pasaría si tenemos algo
exactamente al revés vámonos a este
ejemplo de acá que son máquinas que
venden refrescos y comida máquinas
dispensadoras y entonces vamos a ver qué
sucede en este caso aquí hay una máquina
ya que hay otras sales son dos entonces
esta es la máquina número uno de la
máquina número dos y supongamos que nos
fijamos en la cantidad de cocas
demandadas ahí hay una lata de coca y
hay una lata de coca entonces queremos
ver cuántas bocas se demandan en esta
máquina de acá ahora al principio
pensamos que cada máquina vende las
cocas en 10 pesos y ahorita que vamos a
empezar a jugar vamos a ponerle que está
de aquí no cambia tal entonces esta
máquina de acá no va a cambiar en nada
vamos a fijar en las cocas demandadas en
esta máquina de la izquierda entonces
aquí tenemos el nuevo precio esto va a
estar en pesos por lata y aquí tenemos
cantidad y esto va a ser latas por
semana latas a la semana ok y entonces
al principio tenemos 10 pesos sí o sea
tenemos un precio de 10 pesos por lata y
digamos que se piden 100 latas de coca
en esta máquina casi a la semana también
podemos pensar que aquí se piden 100 si
son máquinas muy similares ahora qué
sucedería si cambiamos el precio si el
precio lo bajamos de 10 pesos a 990 pues
el precio lo bajamos de 10 pesos a 990
ahora lo que va a suceder es que la
gente va a venir va a ver que acá está
la coca más barata en realidad no hay
diferencia entre comprar aquí y acá
vamos a pensar que no hay fila ni nada
entonces las personas van a preferir
comprar acá porque después de comprar
mucho se van a poder ahorrar dinero
comprando sus datos en sus latas de coca
de este lado entonces ahora todas las
personas que compraban en la máquina 2
ya no van a comprar ahí y van a comprar
acá y la cantidad pasa a 200 de modo
similar si el precio lo aumentamos en 10
centavos
ahora las personas van a decir la
máquina 12 es la barata todos van a
empezar a comprar en la máquina 2 y aquí
ya no se va a vender nada muy bien como
se vería la gráfica y bueno
vamos a ponerla por acá
vamos a ponerla de este lado
entonces cómo se vería la máquina de
este lado tenemos cantidad de este lado
tenemos precio entonces cuando el precio
es 10 se demandan 100 100 latas a la
semana sin embargo si el precio aumenta
tantito ya no se demanda nada entonces
este sería otro punto sobre la curva de
demanda pero si bajamos tantito el
precio ahora se demandan 200 200 latas a
la semana entonces cómo se vería la
curva de demanda pues tendríamos que
unir estos puntitos de acá y ahora
tendríamos una curva de demanda casi
horizontal si sería una curva de demanda
casi horizontal conforme vamos haciendo
cambios más y más pequeños podemos ver
que si quedaría más o menos como algo
horizontal en este caso decimos que
tenemos un bien
este muy elástico si no está totalmente
horizontal pero si lográramos que la
curva quedara así totalmente horizontal
si quedara totalmente horizontal
entonces esto de aquí sería un bien
perfectamente perfectamente
elástico elástico ahora hay que también
hacer los cuentitos de la elasticidad de
la demanda ahorita no las voy a hacer
explícitamente lo voy a dejar para que
tú lo hagas pero más o menos qué va a
pasar pues ahora qué sucede ahora
tenemos cambios muy pequeños en el
precio ahora tenemos un denominador muy
muy pequeño y arriba tenemos una
cantidad muy grande arriba es muy grande
entonces si hacen las cuentas de la
elasticidad de la demanda para esta
máquina de cocas te va a dar una una
cantidad muy muy grande así que conforme
vamos haciendo variaciones más y más
pequeñas en el precio entonces nos da
pues igual la misma variación de 200
latas de coca pero pero como era la
variación de precios más pequeña estamos
dividiendo entre algo más pequeño y
podemos pensar que eso de ahí se va a
infinito entonces en un bien
perfectamente elástico lo que tenemos es
que el valor absoluto de la elasticidad
de la demanda es igual a infinito otra
vez en el ejemplo de la coca no es
infinito de hecho es imposible tener un
bien perfectamente elástico pero
conforme vamos haciendo pequeños cambios
la cantidad se hace muy muy muy muy
grande y cuando nos vamos al límite así
ahora sí cuando estamos muy
aquí podemos pensar que esté bien es
perfectamente elástico y por tanto la
elasticidad de su demanda es infinito